- [Voiceover] What I hope to do in this video
is give ourselves an appreciation
for the sodium-potassium pump,
and as the name implies, it pumps
sodium and potassium, but it does it
in different directions.
So this little depiction right over here,
this is my drawing, my rendition
of the sodium-potassium pump,
it's a trans-membrane, I guess you could say
protein complex right over here.
And in this resting state,
it is open to the inside of the cell
and it has an affinity for sodium ions.
And so the sodium ions,
you see three sodium ions
depicted here in blue.
They're going to bind to the pump.
And once they bind to it,
then it's going to want to be
phosphorylated by an ATP,
and we see that right over here.
This is ATP,
adenosine triphosphate.
And when it gets phosphorylated,
it's a release of energy
and it allows the confirmation
of the actual protein to change.
So the new confirmation of the protein,
it's now going to open up
to the outside, close off to the inside,
and now it's no longer going to
have an affinity for sodium ions,
but an affinity for potassium ions,
and this is fascinating,
that release of energy, change of confirmation,
that these proteins really are
these molecular machines,
these fascinating molecular machines.
But once that happens,
this change of confirmation,
the sodium ions are going to
be released outside of the cell.
And then you're going to have potassium ions
that are going to bind from the outside.
And then once that happens,
the change in confirmation,
we're going to have a,
it's going to get dephosphorylated
and then you're going to go back
to your original confirmation,
your original confirmation right over here.
Where you no longer have an affinity
for potassium ions,
they're going to be released,
and then you're going to be
back in the original phase.
So this is fascinating.
By using ATP, by using energy,
this is active transport,
it takes energy to do this.
Let me write this down.
This is active,
this is active transport
that we are talking about
right over here.
We're able to pump,
using an ATP, we're able to pump
three sodium ions out,
so let me write that down.
Three sodium ions out.
And in the process, we pump
two potassium ions in.
So we pump two
potassium ions in.
Now you might say, okay,
the outside, since these both have positive charge,
but I have three sodium going out,
two potassium going in.
That must make the outside
more positive than the inside,
and that actually is true.
But that by itself isn't fully responsible.
It's actually only partially responsible
for the electric potential difference
between the inside of the membrane
and the outside of the membrane.
What really sets that up is that
you actually have channel proteins
that allow potassium ions
to move down, to diffuse down
their concentration gradient.
So let's think about what happens
before I even talk about
these channel proteins right over here.
Because of the sodium-potassium pump,
what is sodium's concentration gradient?
Well, it has a higher concentration
on the outside,
it has a higher concentration on the outside
and it has a lower concentration
on the inside.
This is sodium's concentration gradient.
What is potassium's concentration gradient?
Well, potassium is getting pumped in
from the outside into the cell.
So potassium has the opposite concentration gradient.
It has a high concentration inside
and it has a low concentration outside.
Now if we let potassium go through,
we've talked in previous videos
about ions just not being that,
that just the general membrane,
if it's not facilitated in some way,
isn't that permeable to things like ions,
like sodium and potassium ions.
But if you have channel proteins
right over here that let the potassium
get out, what's going to happen?
Well, you might have one of two answers.
You might say, oh, well, look.
Hey, you know, things diffuse down
their concentration gradient,
you have a higher probability since you have
more potassium here than up here,
higher probability of them
going in the right direction on this side
and moving from this side to that side
than you have them going from that side to that side.
And so you would have a net outflow of potassium.
And some of you might say, well, okay,
that makes sense if you only care
about the concentration gradient.
But what happens if we look at the charge?
Because we're saying that the inside of the cell
is going to be less positive
and the outside of the cell
is going to be more positive
because it has more,
that we have the net ion change,
so it's gonna be more positive out here.
So positive ions, they don't like,
you want to move away from charges
that are the same as you.
You want to move to the places
that are a more negative,
so you'd say, well, these potassium ions
are positively charged,
why would they wanna go from
a less positive place to a more positive place?
And if you are saying either one of these things,
talking about the concentration gradient
or talking about the electric potential difference,
you are actually going to be right in both cases.
These are going to be balancing forces.
The concentration gradient
is going to allow some of
these potassium ions to pour out,
but the concentrations of potassium ions
aren't going to fully equalize
because of the electric potential difference,
because, hey, it's more positive out here,
it's less positive here.
When they're moving out,
they're going against what
their charge wants to do.
They're going with the concentration gradient,
but at some point, that is going to balance out.
And by going through this process,
by pumping sodium out
and with that larger ratio
than what you're pumping potassium in,
and then you're further allowing
more positive charge to go out.
You're establishing what's called
the resting membrane potential for a cell.
And this is super important for all cells,
but especially neuron cells
or neural cells or neurons.
And those are gonna spend
two-thirds of their energy
just to establish or to keep
their resting membrane potential.
And as we'll see in the videos on neurons,
that's because they keep leveraging that potential
to send signals down the neuron.
But the resting membrane potential,
it's less positive here and more positive there.
If you measure this relative to,
let me make that a little bit neater,
relative to this right over here,
this difference is, depending on
what estimates you look at,
approximately negative 70 millivolts.
I've seen estimates negative 60, negative 80.
Negative 70 millivolts.
And this is key for neurons,
but it's key for all cells.
Now the sodium-potassium pump
isn't just about establishing
the resting membrane potential.
Having this higher sodium concentration
on the outside can also be used later on
for other forms of active transport.
When they move down their gradient,
you can do things like
co-transport glucose molecules.
So these biological systems
are far more complicated than
I often give credit for in these videos,
but I want to give you a full appreciation for this.
And just so you know how big of a deal
the sodium-potassium pump was,
it was discovered in the 1950s,
but the 1997 Nobel Prize was awarded
for the discovery of
the sodium-potassium pump
and how it works.